[Música]
el consejo de seguridad de la onu
discutirá este martes la situación en
myanmar tras el golpe de estado en ese
país asiático
eeuu señaló que responderá si los
responsables no revierten sus acciones y
liberan a los líderes del gobierno la
unión europea condenó enérgicamente el
golpe de estado y defendió la transición
democrática
la farmacéutica alemana vaya ante que
informó que entregara 75 millones de
dosis de su vacuna desarrollada en
conjunto con facer durante el segundo
trimestre del año el anuncio se produce
el mismo día en que la unión europea
informó que ha recibido un total de 18,5
millones de dosis del fármaco the
fighter iv 854.000 de modernas
europa se debate entre las re aperturas
y las restricciones una parte de italia
reabrió bares y restaurantes hasta las 6
de la tarde pero mantiene su toque de
queda nocturno francia continúa la
prohibición de viajar desde y hacia
países de fuera de la unión europea y
ante la crítica situación hospitalaria
en portugal austria se ofreció a acoger
a pacientes graves
bienvenidos a esta emisión de noticias
en france 24 soy valentina torres
sánchez y es un gusto acompañarlos
iniciamos este informativo con el
rechazo internacional al golpe de estado
en mianmar el consejo de seguridad de
naciones unidas discutirá la crisis este
martes al tiempo que la alta comisionada
para los derechos humanos michelle
bachelet recordó que el ejército de
mianmar está obligado a respetar la ley
internacional de derechos humanos
bachelet informó que al menos 45
personas entre ellas la líder del
gobierno avanzan succi permanecen
detenidas por el ejército
eeuu aseguró que responderá si los
responsables no se retractan y liberan a
los capturados y la unión europea china
y australia se unieron a la condena
internacional
si no es un vecino amistoso de mianmar y
espera que las distintas partes en el
país resuelvan adecuadamente sus
diferencias bajo el marco constitucional
y legal para proteger la estabilidad
política y social de la crisis en
mianmar estalló luego de la captura de
los líderes del gobierno entre ellos la
consejera de estado and san suu kyi y el
presidente win mint el ejército declaró
el estado de emergencia y anunció que
toma el control del país durante un año
los militares argumentan su actuar
asegurando que hubo fraude en las
elecciones de noviembre pasado en las
que el partido oficialista logró una
aplastante victoria con el 83% de los
asientos en el parlamento
tras meses de tensiones latentes el
ejército de mianmar ha llevado a cabo lo
que muchos temían un golpe de
estado-militar en un mensaje transmitido
a través de un canal de televisión que
pertenece a los militares se anunció que
el ejército tomaba el control del país
durante un año
con el fin de llevar a cabo el
escrutinio de las listas de votantes y
tomar medidas
la autoridad de la legislación la
gobernanza y la jurisdicción de la
nación se transfiere al comandante en
jefe en conformidad con el artículo 418
sub artículo a tomar acaben sigue
luchando yo también perdí el partido
gobernante de mianmar aseguró que aún
son sus y fue arrestada en una redada
matutina junto con otras figuras
importantes del oficialismo un
movimiento significativo que se produce
el día que se suponía que el parlamento
se reuniría por primera vez desde las
elecciones de noviembre desde esa
votación las tensiones han aumentado
entre los líderes civiles del país y sus
poderosos militares los líderes del
ejército afirman que las elecciones que
aún sanssouci ganó de forma aplastante
fueron fraudulentas los informes de los
medios dicen que se cortaron las líneas
telefónicas
internet en la capital y la televisión
estatal no pudo transmitir también ha
habido informes de soldados en las
calles de las grandes ciudades las
condenas en todo el mundo por lo
ocurrido no han tardado washington
amenazó con una respuesta si los líderes
civiles no son liberados aún sanssouci
ha dirigido mianmar durante los últimos
cinco años en el pasado fue vista como
un icono de la paz en occidente pero su
liderazgo se ha visto empañado por el
trato brutal a la minoría musulmana
rohingya del país considerada por
naciones unidas como un pueblo sin
estado
cambiamos de tema y vamos a europa la
comisión europea anunció que bryant y
fisher entregarán 75 millones de dosis
de su vacuna contra el cob y 19 en el
segundo trimestre del año lo que se suma
a las 9 millones de dosis adicionales a
las que se comprometió astrazéneca hasta
marzo el bloque indicó que ha recibido
un total de 18,5 millones de dosis del
fármaco de facer y 854 mil de modernas
nuestra corresponsal en bruselas esther
herrera nos amplía
tras una mejora en los procesos de
producción la farmacéutica pfiezer
biotech ha anunciado que distribuirá 75
millones de dosis adicionales a la unión
europea a partir del 15 de febrero
después algunos problemas en la planta
de fabricación de bélgica de la
farmacéutica que había ralentizado la
distribución provocando el pánico en
algunos países finalmente la compañía ha
asegurado que ya está dispuesta a
distribuir todas las dosis necesarias
por la unión europea en total la
comisión europea tiene contratadas 600
millones de dosis con fisher además la
comisión europea ha anunciado que por el
momento ya se ha distribuido 18 5
millones de dosis y que se podrá cumplir
el objetivo que de aquí a septiembre ya
se hayan distribuido 600 millones de
dosis después de una semana pasada en
que la comisión europea le han arreciado
las críticas después de los problemas
con hasta zénica y también críticas a su
gestión en la comisión europea estaba
ávida de buenas noticias y de hacer
'borrón y cuenta nueva'
por el momento ya se ha aplicado el
nuevo mecanismo de las vacunas
desde el pasado fin de semana todas las
vacunas que se fabriquen en suelo
europeo solo se podrán exportar con la
previa autorización de los países
europeos y el continente europeo que ha
registrado más de 34 millones de
contagios lucha por controlar los nuevos
casos parte de italia en un respiro para
sus ciudadanos reabrió bares y
restaurantes hasta las 6 de la tarde
pero mantiene su toque de queda nocturno
la crítica situación que atraviesa
portugal llevó al gobierno austríaco a
ofrecer ayuda y francia continúa con sus
restricciones de viajes desde y hacia
países fuera de la unión europea nuestra
periodista natalia ruiz nos da más
detalles
desde este domingo a la medianoche para
poder salir de francia con destino a un
país afuera de la unión europea se
necesita un motivo de fuerza mayor el
fallecimiento de un familiar alguna
cuestión de salud o un motivo
profesional que no puede ser postergado
no ha sido un día fácil para los
viajeros aquí en el aeropuerto charles
de gaulle de parís hablamos con algunos
de ellos una ciudadana canadiense que
decía tener todos los papeles en regla
tanto para salir de francia como para
entrar a canadá pero que consideraba que
la situación era bastante angustiante
también hablamos con un viajero que
debía ir a turquía para visitar a su
hermana hospitalizada sin embargo como
no tenía ningún papel que apoyar a esto
pues no pudo viajar no lo permitieron
porque es aquí la policía de frontera si
ustedes ven a mis espaldas la encargada
de dar la última palabra de decir si los
justificativos entregados pues sí
ameritan ese desplazamiento la verdad es
que francia espera que con estas nuevas
medidas se pueda evitar un tercer
confinamiento cuando en las últimas
semanas los casos diarios sobrepasan
20.000 por ahora estas restricciones de
viaje estarán en vigor hasta nueva orden
finalizamos en israel que es la
referencia a nivel global en la
vacunación contra el hobbit 19 el país
tiene alrededor de 9 millones de
habitantes y casi el 50% de su población
ha recibido al menos una dosis el 15% se
ha vacunado de forma completa el proceso
busca llevar al país a una inmunización
colectiva en marzo pero detrás existe un
contrato exclusivo con fighter en el que
se cree que hay sobreprecios y cesión de
datos a la compañía veamos el informe de
álvaro cordero
israel podría ser el primer país en
dejar atrás las típicas imágenes del
confinamiento con apenas 9 millones de
habitantes casi 3 millones han recibido
al menos una dosis y de ellos la mitad
también recibió la segunda algo que ha
hecho que las imágenes de fiestas
vuelvan y que los jóvenes estén
empezando a vacunarse ya que vine aquí
para vacunarme estudio en bachillerato y
es importante que volvamos a la
normalidad y nos deshagamos del
coronavirus ya que volvamos a
encontrarnos con nuestros amigos a
estudiar de forma normal y no el zoom en
mojado quiero todo lópez con casi 55
dosis por cada 100 habitantes la brecha
que separa a israel del resto de los
países es muy grande reino unido apenas
llega a 14 bahrein a 10 y eeuu no supera
las 9 el objetivo es llegar a la
inmunización colectiva en marzo pero
porque avanza tan rápido la vacunación
la explicación parece tener dos
respuestas posibles sobrecostes en la
compra de las vacunas y un contrato
preferencial con fai ser valiente que
israel es un socio prioritario a cambio
de entregar datos sanitarios a la
compañía y demostrar sus resultados a
nivel masivo y esto
parecen ser muy positivos ya que sólo el
0 015 de las personas inmunizadas con la
segunda dosis se ha contagiado ninguna
con síntomas graves
creo que lo importante no es simplemente
lo que hemos hecho por israel sino el
hecho de que israel puede servir como un
caso de prueba global real y
verdaderamente global 3 que es el caso
de israel contrasta con el de palestina
que está sufriendo una nueva ola de la
pandemia y que no puede gozar del mismo
programa de vacunación las autoridades
tienen que alcanzar por su cuenta los
acuerdos y apenas han recibido cinco mil
dosis de israel'
a ustedes gracias por acompañarnos
volvemos en unos momentos con más
noticias estos france24
[Música]